you pay you go in the S and you like
they take pictures and they have the
little thing but it's different it's
like just a mirror and she rented out to
parties and she's making her own little
money man but uh that's just a relevant
comment but uh uh where' you grow up
where you from I was born in Glendo 1997
January 6 1997 um my full name is
Gustavo Alejandro ordones on my
California ID and on my social security
card is gust aland CA my social security
number is
46 that's where I was born in Glend
Hospital Gustavo uh tell me about your
childhood tell me about your parents uh
my parents uh they have we we live in uh
Hawthorne oh not we they live in
Hawthorne um as a child uh I was
uh n drug non drug addict uh played
soccer a y so had uh acquaintances or
friends
um was always insecure around woman and
didn't know why but now I can see that
it was because of my weight
uh I started doing bulimia at like
156 uh because I noticed that uh some
women were attracted to male male bodies
that and it's not a B thing and uh as I
grew up my parents were very loving very
they were together they they are now
divorced but when it through like zero
to let's just say play sa 17 they were
together and they gave me everything I
needed I never had to worry about milk
or paying rent or working um my first
job was um no the best job I've had and
I could brag about of it is LA Fitness
sales I think that's where I would learn
how to speak and communicate
assertively uh but I doubt myself and I
also think that I'm not as smart as I
should believe I am and I worked at
Denny's as bus boy warehouse jobs very
uh physical jobs where I know that um
I've studied and uh information that I
think I can share with the world that
for example like chess I don't know if
no one notices why does uh White go
first you know isn't that kind of like
uh rude and like a racist and then uh
what's another question mark I'm just
blabbing way so you were a thin believe
believe you you were heavy or you were
two my way I most have weighed uh was I
was uh I got in I got arrested my meth
has brought me good things and negative
hold on so as a kid you were too heavy
or too he heavy not in Rex here heavy
like uh I have pictures too if they want
to proof I have pictures and I had a
where did you weigh as a kid I mean I
can't recall but if you saw my pictures
you could see a doctor can be like yeah
that's or passing obese is obese or fat
you know and uh I was insecure man and
uh when I was introduced to marijuana
and cocaine at 1819 I uh there was like
a radical switch in me everything that I
did so I did the opposite instead of
eating I didn't eat instead of uh just
sleeping I was active instead of uh
being in Secure I was very confident and
uh I have my relationship with women
High School Natalie I don't want to burn
them out or say nothing disrespectful
but very uh women have inspired me I
believe that men if men don't have uh
Woman as a motivation they are uh going
to
probably not care I mean the main
motivation for a straight man and my
thing not to be rude to anybody is to
have a woman why do you get a nice to
show off to the ladies why do you work
out to show off to unless should like uh
have a different uh preference of sex
which is none of my business I respect
you know but not me you know but uh and
cooking got too expensive and I tried
methampetamine and it was like this is
my [__] and this a coincidence that's
what they call it you know [__] but
uh I was I I not going to tell myself
like oh yeah you know a lot of I've been
to rehabs a lot and they told me oh me
the bad and I agree to a certain extent
that it may affect your uh psyche and uh
uh your dehydration system
and um if you abuse it it might abuse
you but something that benefited I've
gotten relationships with woman and and
I can guarantee most of it some part is
due to the methany and the the
confidence in provisor like right now
I'm under the influence 100% And I hope
this is this doesn't get used against me
because I've been immature and
irresponsible and I've been gone to jail
for a possession of meth it has brought
me negative consequence crystal meth
gives you confidence yeah no but it has
brought me negative consequences like
been arrested for possession you know
and I lost two years of my life I was at
project 180 uh where they declare you I
was declared incompetent in court uh and
they sent me to uh which is not which I
believe I was doing saying the opposite
I think the woman was just um confused
on what I said and she just made a
decision and declared me incompetent
which turned out to be a good thing
because instead of doing two years in
Twin Towers I did two years at project
180 which is a uh where they they send
you from jail to the program and you you
meet up with the judge every um month or
every week or if you relaps they put you
uh they um so you clean for a while yeah
yeah I was clean and I gained 200 and I
have it I have a picture I'll show you I
have a picture of my ID and uh my facial
stret I Will Wait 2 85 280 lbs tops
right now I weigh 190 something and I
feel way more energetic I feel not slump
meaning not tired not just wanting to
sleep and uh have like fear and
insecurity when was the last time you
slept uh one day and a half ago around
not to be specific but you'll go days
without sleep yeah I will go days
without sleep however I was aware of
this and I knew that that might affect
like there was a Russian science
experiment where they were up for days
and they started losing them I believe
that occurs but uh I don't force myself
to sleep more than the most I've done
without sleeping and it's not something
I'm trying to brag it's 5 days and I was
still in my mind in my opinion I was
confident I would have a conversation
with someone but yes I was I'll be like
well I'm kind of tired you know but it's
not something I promote it's not
something I'm not promoting methany if
you find alternative like uh I'm glad I
met mark because I feel that he has 3.8
million views in a a video you guys I
have a YouTube channel too and I talk
about the Bible which is something
religion is something really sensitive
to everybody and I should say I 13
subscribers really proud of you Mark and
I hope uh uh so what what are you doing
with your life now what I'm doing with
my life uh I'm training for 2020
Olympics uh I don't know if I could
without I want I mastered my martial
arts what is your sport uh kickboxing
but Muhammad Ali in in an anime show
you're like oh he K in the anime show
called baky really famous he it's a
really good fighter tell uh Muhammad Ali
uh oh Muhammad Ali I created my own
boxing and I created my own karate and
TMO I've have like five kicks I can
perform but I'm going to use three at
the Olympics if I'm connected somehow to
go the only problem is I'm a myth but I
found a solution you get Adon prescribed
you know it has amphetamine doesn't have
the chemicals and I'll get drink some C4
with the right amounts and uh some
energy boosters and I feel that I I will
defeat whoever is in front of me I've
seen these guys fight on YouTube and not
to be real they're pathetic in my not
pathetic but obviously they got there
for a reason but I know how I'll defeat
them you feel me you're telling me
kickboxer on yeah take one on Skid Row
is going to kick their ass yeah hell
yeah I'll show you have you ever seen
karate like this Mark uh let me
see okay that's pretty [__] quick
that's my main kick in the
in okay that's my and there my weakness
the only three kicks I use and I'm be
skipping
around I will beat him
yeah muhamad Al M Tyson was a drug
addict and people doubted him a lot and
uh Mike Tyson was a drug addict just see
what I'm assuming he does talk about
about uh or uses drugs I don't know if
he use them um I'll talk about L Dias
how about that yes Nate is a USC F and
he smokes marijuana and has you're out
of breath I know a little bit I just
think you're going to go around I mean I
can keep going but um speaking and
multitasking I'm fine I'm fine but Nate
this is uh was a as um we JN Jones bro
undefeated and the heavyweight cocaine
atct and I believe that and one fight I
think he was on cocaine when he beat uh
uh his his opponent was a Aries uh he he
does a commentary with Joe Rogan are you
know talking about black guy I don't
watch that stuff well UFC well uh his I
can't forget anyways Jon Jon is
undefeated to this if if I'm not
mistaken uh and he was on cocaine and he
won that does mean the being under the
influence is it's up to you to have the
self does it dominate you or you
dominate it you know does it uh are you
going to be uh feeling regret Gustavo I
think this might be the meth
talking no I don't think so I think I'm
not say I'm not defending it I'm not
saying it's a good thing or a bad thing
it's up to the user of how he
channelizes what the uh drug produces in
you the drug mathan for me prod energy
alertness and all that and I may seem
like I'm in hypermania state which is
what
the opposite of so bipolar is either
you're in depression or you're in hyper
Manus and when I get on meth and I'm in
hyper Manus what does that mean very
alert very like cautious or paranoid and
of course this is my only position you
won't pass a drug test though yeah I
won't but I could get ad or prescribed
it's aetam it has what meth has but it's
the legal way and I'm just being
brutally honest you got all because I
I've been being very honest when I'm
sober and I do karate I don't in my
opinion maybe if I got the right
training and right motivation some
cheerleaders that are 21 and over cuz I
am very respectful of the age of and
everything was settled the law so you
respect woman and they're like hey you
could do it man or come on babe you know
I'll be like [__] even I over or on ader
I'll win cuz I'm not going to fail uh
the repetition of my ladies and make
them look at bad in 2020 I'll be I'm 26
uh so in 2020 I don't know if I'll be 31
or 32 I'm terrible at math but what's
wor
I can say
um I I can say I'm better than that math
you know what's another question mark to
be I I don't know if I'm so where where
are you staying now you're on the I'm a
SK R Midnight Mission and the other day
uh you stay in a tent or no no tent I
sleep in the oh yeah I got in
altercation with uh you know this is
this gives me very uh this brings a
little bit of Shame on myself because I
used to ridicule and offend people that
be like oh you know the people that take
out anger on I be like oh dude how I a
tri con and I ended up doing the same
thing why did I do it uh long story
short as long story amend instead of an
apology to I got in trouble with one of
my exes or current girlfriends it's
complicated uh and she said stop
apologizing why don't you to do
something that you feel the same pain I
felt physically not saying that I hit or
emotionally actually emotionally on
yourself so I was like okay what can I I
punch the [__] out of a wall until I uh
it caused my this to be really swollen I
went to uh a hospital and then they cut
me they did perform little surgery and
they put take out puss and this happened
really recently and um blood so cuz my
arm was very like this and uh if I
didn't uh if I didn't uh take it
seriously I could not have an arm right
now bro or half maybe if it was
amputated but
um and you think you're ready for the
Olympics yeah uh right now yeah
definitely uh any I'm I'm a little I
still got some f but I'm trying to turn
it into muscle and uh I have 2028 you
know um with this and I seen people
their kicks and I study what they do
they do slow kicks like uh uh
like I kick
and sidekick and all that that's too
that's too slow you know my kicks are
way faster and I'm a winning for the
United States and I want to prove my mom
wrong cuz she says you're going to fail
you're not going to be nothing she would
tell me look at yourself in the mirror
and I would question I'll be like like
why like to see my reflection or to see
how I look on meth and she hates my
addiction bro my mom hates meth because
I will stay up all night outside of the
house and
H 92 I will stay outside trying to
impress my neighbor not bu uh Rachel
Morales um which is a very she's a
torist and I'm a c and I would impress
her by doing karate and I know she liked
it cuz she would turn on the the
sprinklers when I would do something
real gnarly karate and I thank that
woman cuz she inspired me and
um do you how do you survive what do you
do for money uh EVT right now food
stamps
yes do you have any friends uh women men
I have very little sympathy for I only
associate what's up with people that are
uh like successful or nothing I'm
successful no are like
uh I have very little friends male
friends man I have very little woman
yeah I Sur and Mark uh I saw you pull up
I saw your energy yeah I'm assuming you
just cut straight to like what's your
start I was like d I don't know if just
talk about the future the I mean the
present or the past and but uh thanks
for giving me this opportunity and uh if
you can connect me Mike to somehow the
Olympics and I have to fight the guy uh
that that's going to represent American
T I will defeat him but give me like I
don't think that's how it works oh I
mean who it will just show who's better
right there you know and I'll defeat him
and if I'm me and he's like oh but
you're using a Dr so [__] I'll
use that on I'll still but if you gave
me three more months of training and you
can train I'mma Be trust even harder
because I'm have I'm train I'm I've been
busy occupied cuz I saw a Red Bull you
know like oh Red Bull they sued Red Bull
for some guy said that it doesn't give
them wings and it's not a performance
inance okay I get you the Wings part
they lie there but that not a
performance that's an opinion if I was a
lawy I'd be like I'll counter that I'll
be like it gave me a performance it gave
me energy and he wouldn't have got the
money and I want to let you know about
that and like McDonald's put a
commercial on audio mac uh less than 6
months ago and people get references it
uh they said oh me me McDonald's
something similar to this not to be I
had to be precise with you oh we cook
Fast breakfast faster than anybody and
that's a that's a opinion if someone uh
did a a social experiment where they
have cameras like this and they cooked
the MCG gdle faster than them they lied
and you can sue them seriously M uh
appearances so so you're a kickboxer I'm
a kickboxer and have you ever competed
uh uh never competed doesn't mean I'm
going to lose or anything it does not
mean you're going to lose no it doesn't
but but I have the but it it doesn't
that it I noticed that when I do karate
around uh people have told me that
they've never seen karate and Marshals
like I do and Mike tson has the same
Aurora as me I get really competitive
when it's time to get down bro and uh I
know that my reputation is on the line
and wom I represent is on the line I'm
not going to lose and I I will win first
place for United St if it's help if it's
not I'll just watching for my for my uh
TV not TV but somewhere if I ever get to
watch it on YouTube after it occurs if I
don't get there which will break my
heart cuz I know I'll win for United I
think Poland won and know this guy
looked pathetic I was like this K and
I'm going to be sooning and moving and I
want to get you and it's points it's not
like a UFC fight where it's like uh
there's no technical it's technical it's
technical could take one up a points and
then they separate you and I'm I'm going
just do a tech I used to be a Defender
for soccer back Center back and uh
that's when I had really great memories
of my dad and my mom uh when they were
together not saying that you've been
using since when uh I just say 21 years
old I'm 26 5 years five years and I've
paid you lose weight to lose weight G
you confidence with women women and it's
going to send you to Olympics hell yeah
but I need to make sure that I don't BS
whoever if I get link with the with the
with um Olympic the wi to train him and
I tell hey look I would me but I need
met up prescribe if you want to
guarantee a win like if you want to see
me on C4 or the best energy drinks or
whatever uh so be I'll try to I'll
maximize and make sure I abuse it so
make sure I'm on the similar level as
meth you know but ad all take what the
normal dosage you know 100 milligrams
and uh uh I take a C4 and I take some
Red Bull even if I might get a part rate
cardiac but for that moment only for
that moment when it's time to fight the
my opponent and I'm going to do some
psychology I'm going be like you're
going to lose without
doubt and not just messing
psychologically up maybe maybe I'm
assuming and I'll be like you're going
to lose and I'll start boom and attack
front kick and if that doesn't hit him
left and I'm injured I hit with my left
right now I'm riding man and I think
that was a pretty severe strike maybe
maybe like sh but um my right is my this
my stron
hand I think this is like I I was right
here I was like Gustavo don't [__] this
up this can either go make you really
depressed cuz you [__] up the
interview or you can go viral and be a
motivation like my one of my goals or
dream is to have my own Dojo you know
and train the youth not I won't train
them of right there why because uh I'm
not a [__] pedophile straight up or a
sex and I know how severe it is to
disrespect the youth and or be attracted
to a Mone [__] that [__] in jail they
kill you for that [__] bro it's straight
up
they find out they ask for your
paperwork it's like oh I don't know why
way I'm here give me your [__]
paperwork oh sex oh we got a Chester the
laughter you feel me it's like and then
so for that reason you're not going to
I'm not going to train youth I'll train
18 and over or 21 and over some or uh
because um in my opinion when you're a
kid you're still like not taking you may
take it very serious like in China they
train them from very young I'm assuming
to but sometimes they abuse the the the
the consequences and the psych that
they're nervous in the moment of of the
Olympics you know they're so scared
they're going to get in trouble for not
doing a perfect t or you know and United
States is uh um the best country in the
world no one's going to mess with us you
mean no one has only the one oh yeah the
kamakazi they were I heard I assume they
were on some fields that are similar to
men so they can have the courage to dude
to Suicide bomb you know you have to be
on some type of CH you don't have to but
it's rumored you know and uh yeah man uh
I do this and I'm going go home in hotor
and I'm going claim my where I used to
do my dips is my favorite exercise
calisthenics and uh uh my own training
with the legs is I do very basic
training but
um training is overrated training can be
training is not overrated well it's an
OP that's in your opinion if you're
using meth you don't need to that's in
opinion why if I use meth if I use meth
I'm going to make sure that I uh uh
maximize it um it's uh I'm going to take
advantage of it I'm not just going to be
like if you're going to do an uper on
drugs do something active cuz so your
blood stream could flow you and you
you're like H but you know going at it
you know uh what does that mean like
uh you're using the drug for what it's
trying to it's affect like if you smoke
weed and and you're trying to run a
marathon like it's okay you know why not
but uh I think weed is like a downer you
know and if alcohol can be like B it
depends on the person but I'm going do
some water man the meth meth is your
meth
is if I die using drug meth I will be uh
not s I'll be like uh I know the the
horrible part is when I found out like I
was in Project 180 which is like uh
where they send what I was telling uh
that they replacing with the F that
shit's scary you know every time I not
every time I use it but sometimes when I
get a second W you know man sometimes
I'm like [__] this [__] this [__] can
kill me you feel me but uh it's a worth
it's a risk I'm worth taking just like
when people gamble their houses on a
game of of of uh the the Super Bowl you
know I do meth you know and everyone has
their own some people have uh um an
addiction to food so be I don't judge
you know that makes it so be you know
but uh that's how people have addiction
to gambling all that you know I don't I
don't even like saying the word cuz um
I'm a I feel consider myself a role
model and I feel like I've been
ridiculed by my parents by them going
outside and like what are you doing I'm
my mom like she doesn't she has never
complimented me bro on a karate kick
that I've done and that [__] breaks my
[__] heart dog because I know my
karate has made I've done social
experience where I see beautiful women
and I'm like does she look 21 and over
I'm like hopefully she's I'm not going
to check out just in just in case I
don't because I don't know her age for
sure and I don't know her but I'm going
run past her and I'm going to do a swing
and I'm just check her for a reaction
and and when they done they be like who
and [__] I'm like yes but I be like hell
yeah I turned around hell no cuz I
didn't confirm her age you know and I
move on but I've gotten uh I've seen
people be like dude that's pretty nor
and my my my my my uh neighbor Rachel
would turn on the sprinklers every time
I would do a good training and good
karate and I hit her up on Instagram and
she didn't follow me back that broke I
don't know what the I don't know if
she's playing mind games or not but um
maybe she but I we did speak and all
right Gustavo thank you so much for any
sharing your story I wish you all the
luck in the world and the you're going
to need some dang man I feel like that's
we left it on a a bad right did I do
anything bad no no no you can post this
on YouTube uh I just want some uh social
support where someone Believes In Me and
tells me dude I got you I'm going to
give you the benefit of the down I'm
going see I'm going compare you to the
other guy that was going to represent
the United States of America and karate
share a little bit of WI wisdom with us
before we wisdom take your own advice
you know people be like oh I be like go
she should do this or he should do this
app it to yourself and
U my favorite Bible verse and that's
yeah oh they brought religions my
favorite Bible verse is this Hebrews
13:16 out of all the Bible is this do
not forget to do good with others
because for with such sacrifices what
sacrifice the act of doing good with
others and sometimes that means uh
giving them the benefit of the doubt
even if they're a tweaker on Scaro you
feel me uh plank T came from the the
Brooklyn or something that's a hood area
you feel me Muhammad Ali rep represented
the the um the black civil or something
Hara tman bro will risk going back and
getting slaughtered potentially she got
caught like that's courage bro and I
feel like I got that Aurora too you know
that energy you know you're going to
have one hell of a story going from skid
rad to the win winning the Olympics yeah
why not and I saw hey can bro and I'm a
dud bro and if I say oh I might lose
you're already you're already
losing